oh boy
it's happening hot breath the verse
welcome back
to the hot breath podcast the show where
you learn comedy from the pros
i am comedian joel byers this is our
series comedians on skype talking comedy
where you get to ask your favorite
comedians your favorite
comedy questions if you are watching
this on youtube
or listening on the podcast all of these
q a's do happen
in our facebook group so go into the
description join our facebook group to
be involved with all the different
writing clubs and different additional
content we have going on
as well as interacting with comedians
like today's amazing guest we have
please welcome
to the hot breathaverse miss emily
catalano ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the show
oh there we go yeah i was doing an
applause sound effect there it is
awesome well welcome hey am i here
you're
you are you're on the internet now
welcome to the show
thank you i love
or i mean we'll yeah we'll get into it
but i love it seemingly
first how long have you been doing
comedy
um five years five years about five
years yeah
cool so yeah people you can go ahead and
start posting questions but um
something that i think people enjoy
about your comedy at least what i enjoy
when i first stumbled upon you
is like you seem to be able to marry
how you are off stage and bring it on
stage
and only five years in i mean that's
you're ahead of the curve in a lot of
ways it takes comedians several years to
figure out that balance but
are you aware of that is that something
you're conscious of or does it just kind
of happen and you're like i mean that's
just what it is
i think i'm aware of it now but when i
first started
i just i sort of was like just lucky
like that's just how i
uh well it was just like the same way on
stage that i am
like right now and i guess like like i
didn't know that was unique
um but now i realize like oh yeah that's
like
pretty hard to do is just like i have
that voice
that like unique voice on stage and off
stage
so i got like uh
pretty lucky i guess that this is the
only voice that i
can do but how you said you at least
weren't aware of it at first but how did
you start to
become aware of how you're funny off
stage and start to bring it on stage
dude i don't know i'm still figuring
that out but
um yeah i think it's just like the more
comfortable you are
the more like you realize like um
like the more natural you can be on
stage the more you have
the audience's attention um so if you
can be real
and like connect with them like then
that's the best thing
for your comedy so i think it's just
i don't know practice
yeah and that's why i was excited about
doing this one this
episode with you which was uh requested
by a listener you were
is you are like seemingly new to comedy
i mean five years versus
people who do this their entire lives
you know i'm 10 years in but i still
consider myself
considerably new based on it being a
lifelong journey
but you being only five years in and
already being able to perform on
conan a comedian we see conan and we're
just like oh they climbed the mountain
you know they they made it type deal how
how did that whole experience come to be
that was crazy um it was
kind of just uh i was in the right place
at the right time
um i started in san francisco
and so i was like working the clubs up
there like punchline and cobs
and i got to do a weekend with pete
holmes
so i was just hosting for pete and
he was like next time you're in la come
do my show
at largo and
so i was like okay whoa yeah that's huge
so i i like planned a trip down there
just to do his show and then a few days
before
i drove down the show got cancelled
um and i he didn't like tell me about it
i like found out on their website or my
friend was like
the show looks like it got cancelled and
i looked it up on the website and it was
canceled so i was like
hey is this show still happening and
he's like
oh sorry about that no it's not
happening
and then like i ended up moving to la
like a few months later after that
and then i was like i'll just hit him up
again and then
because it's like a monthly show so i
hit him up and he was like yeah for sure
come by and i did a set
and it was like amazing it's just like a
really cool theater like the best crowd
um and the owner was there who like
books all the shows and he really liked
me
so he just kept like uh booking me
and got to open for like some like other
comedians
like sarah silverman and tignataro at
morgo
at largo yeah whoa yeah it was just like
this like random like i mean i think
like you know
it helps being like funny but funny
exactly yeah
exactly funny but it's just like it was
like one of those like dreams come
true like moments where you're like um
in the right place at the right time and
now
all these like cool things are happening
to me and then uh
so pete's manager was at a lot of shows
and he's like i've been talking to you
i'm talking about you to jp the conan
booker
um he's like you should send in your
clip
uh from tonight i was like well i
already sent him a clip
and he never got back to me uh
so you know it's not gonna happen
he's like no send in send another one
send your audio
which is like kind of unheard of like
you're not supposed to send audio you're
supposed to send
video but he's like yeah i've been
i've been talking to him about you so
just do it
so i had my manager send in my audio
from that night
and then uh then he got back to us with
like all the jokes that he liked
and then it was like kind of a long
process from there it was like maybe uh
six months after that i was able to
get on air but six months
of like back and forth like is he like
can you change this joke or like what
was the back end for or that process
yeah it was like uh put these drugs
together
uh make a video send it to me um
okay i like that that's good we'll try
to get you on
but like you know going months without
hearing and then
uh then he like was like oh do you want
to do this joke instead of this joke
and then i was like no
or but i was like then we like switched
up the order again
and then i got the like okay we're gonna
we're gonna get you on but it was yeah
it was like i was stressed out like for
six months
just not knowing but then were you
stressed out preparing for it too
i mean and how long i'd love to get in
the preparation but how long
between six months to get the
confirmation
and then how long after okay we want you
are you then
performing on conan so
i got the date for conan one week
and yeah like one week before you're
supposed to do
i had yeah oh my gosh
um for like a definite date
so i had one week so i just like did as
many shows as i could for that week
and it was really easy to get like the
stage time for it because you just have
to say like
hey i'm gonna be on conan next week like
can i do five minutes
it was like it was like the coolest week
because i just i knew my five minutes
like and i knew i was doing conan so it
was just like this
uh i was on this like other level
where i was just like so happy but it
was like
it was like stressful but like after
that week i was like so prepared
um for it and just like ready to like do
it you know get it over with
um and it like it was cool
yeah are you like in your apartment
pacing talking in the mirror like how
how far does the preparation go between
are you transcribing it
like how how fine-tuned was this set
uh just like it couldn't get more
fine-tuned
like i was going over it in my head like
i couldn't sleep
i was just like writing it out like
yeah in the shower just like saying it
over and over again
like it was almost like maybe two
prepared but
i felt like once i was on stage i like
felt good because it was like i don't
need i think i like blanked
like uh blacked out like on stage
i was just like so surreal um but
i'm happy that i was like prepared
what a gnarly experience yeah
it was crazy like you what is that
feeling like
because i've never i went through a
phase where i was like i gotta
i gotta book conan for this like dumb
outside validation thing like i would
still do it of course but like
i wanted to do it for the wrong reason
which i have found in my career any time
those are your intentions
then it won't come to fruition so i've
i've
let go of it since but it there was
moments in my career i'm like
i've got to book conan because then
everything happens but like
you being five years in and you getting
this conan benchmark and you can kind of
put that as a credit now like
is it validating i mean what is that
feeling i didn't get to feel it
how does it feel yeah
well i'll say like yeah like you said
the validation
is probably um the most
uh meaningful to me because it's like my
first
credit um and before that like i
didn't have one like maybe like some
festivals or something right
exactly yeah yeah so it's like um
validation for like other comedians i
think to be like oh conan
okay she's validated
almost in a way but also like for me it
was like a big
like okay i am doing this comedy thing
like if you know
for me like personally it's just like
something
like okay all this hard work like like
five years of
uh you know doing all these shows every
night
it like paid off and that feels really
good but as far as like
i don't know i don't know if like after
doing conan it's not like
i'm a a different
comedian like it's not like gotten me
like a job or anything like i'm not like
um a successful comedian now you know
like i think it's just late night sets
are like different it's not gonna like
boost my career as much as it maybe
would have like 20 years ago
um but it's just um
it's still cool i don't know yeah it is
almost more for comedians now like i
mean i've had several friends perform on
late night and
it is more like it's for us it's for
your peers more than like getting some
sort of opportunity that may or may not
happen it really is just like oh i
conquered that type deal yeah for sure
definitely and one of the um
i want to dive in okay we have some
people posting questions i want to dive
into um a joke
that you did on because i love your
writing and
your timing on stage and there is
there's a confidence to
silence and you say you're only five
years in that's i mean like
silence is something that comedians
i mean oh like 15 years in can struggle
with being comfortable in that but you
do seem to have confidence within your
pacing and your pausing overall and it
how were you able to
develop that especially so quickly
um i think for me i'm just like a slow
person in general
like so i think like listening
is really hard so when i'm listening to
comedians sometimes i'm like
i'm gonna like you're talking so fast
and i i don't really wanna pay attention
to all this so i'm going to think about
something else
so i realized that like pretty early on
like
okay like a really important part is to
just keep the audience's attention
especially when you're like starting out
you're liking these noisy dive bars
or like coffee shops and so if you can
even if you like nobody's laughing if
you can get their attention
and hold it like that feels so good
so i think i just developed that early
on just like trying to get people's
attention
um and i noticed that like the slower i
went
and like the more pauses i took the more
people would be like whoa what's
happening what's going on
um it's like yeah yeah it's like a
little trick
that i learned um and now i just
i don't know it just kind of stuck
but i noticed like i'll go back and like
listen to like newer jokes
that i recorded and like i feel like i'm
talking so
fast yeah so it's like i have to like
really like
learn how to slow down uh my jokes over
time
um i feel like it helps me better like
breathe
like i sometimes if i catch myself going
too fast and early on i would
do some open mics where i was like my
only goal is to just
focus on breathing this set and just
make sure i'm mindful of taking a breath
in between jokes um so breathing helps
me slow down and that was a technique
that helped me to kind of develop
more of a slower pace is that is
breathing important to you or
what do you do when you're like oh i'm
speeding up how do you catch yourself
yeah breathing is a really good i don't
i never think about breathing though i
don't think when i'm performing
it's just so hard to think about that
but um
i think what i think about is
um like laughs once
like i want them to laugh and then i'm
gonna wait until they're done laughing
and wait for them to like finish
processing the last joke before i start
saying something else because i think it
just goes back to like i want them
to pay attention to what i'm saying i'm
up here it's my time
like don't be thinking about the last
joke i said think about this joke that
i'm
saying now and i think that i do that
just like in regular life too because
i'm very quiet
so like i have to wait until there's
like a pause in the conversation
to like if i want people to like pay
attention to me
um so that's just yeah something i've
learned from
like growing up i guess yeah
it's like people will pay attention to
me if they're not distracted by anything
else
i love it and you just to get into a
specific joke
um i mean your basketball coach bit
um i mean the the pacing the
the word choice the timing of some tags
like i mean i love the bit
but how how did you like
develop that bit from an idea
that you then were able to translate
into a bit for
late night yeah so
it's funny because like the original
original idea was like
um like a basketball announcer
well it is like a basketball announcer
because i was watching a lot of
basketball at the time
and like there's so many innuendos so i
was like oh that's kind of funny
so it'd be funny if i did a bit where i
was like a basketball announcer
um but there was like just a bunch of
sexual innuendos
but then like i was like i'm not i can't
do
a basketball announcer like that's not
i can't do characters um
so i think originally i like started i
was like trying to do
like this like fast like back and forth
thing
and it just like wasn't working so i was
like i just gotta like
do it like how i would say it so like
i'm
directing like uh someone you know
um and then like just the tags you try
like a million different tags and those
are the ones
that uh i liked and it had like a good
rhythm
and that's the joke like most often like
people will come up after
the show and be like oh i have a tag for
you but like i've tried them all like
stop giving me tags
like i've tried all of them this these
are the ones that
i like the best and that i've stuck with
so
yeah it is it's fun it's a fun pace and
it is like
piecing it together like a puzzle and
how
what was the process for putting that
puzzle together in terms of like
were you pinned to paper and you wrote
like a bunch of
sexual innuendos and then like a bunch
of sports phrases and you tried to like
connect the dots that way
or how how did you start to kind of find
the mechanics
yeah just that way just trying to think
of as many like funny like one line
things
as i could and then like the different
like players and stuff like i love the
warriors so i was like trying to get
at first i was like trying to get all of
the players in i was like that's too
many and then it was just like way too
long
so i just kept like trying to cut it
down as much as possible but still get
like those i like those like big pops of
laughs
so i would just like keep those and then
like kind of get rid of
everything else yeah
editing can be a beast because it's it's
oh it's my brilliant idea
it's my joke but then if it doesn't
laugh i mean
it's it's you know it's got to go yeah
that's how i
i feel sometimes i edit like too much
because i'm like
oh that one time it didn't get a laugh
so i'm gonna cut it out
and then i'll forget about it but then i
don't know i'm really bad at like
keeping stuff that's not working and
like just trying to make it better but
like
i'll just like cut out so much
it's good though i mean those the stuff
worth keeping always comes back around
so it's always better to be too harsh
where you're like i'll just
kill it and then it'll roll back around
a lot of the times it may be a month and
maybe a year like five years like the
good stuff
will float back to the top so it's
better to have that instinct
i would say than where you have too much
fluff and you just hold everything too
precious
and then you end up just bombing you
just die on your sword
yeah yeah i've done that yeah i've done
that with a few jokes where i'm like i
really like this joke but nobody else
does so i'm gonna keep doing it and then
finally
after like years i was like okay fine
right yeah
i'm not gonna do that but then sometimes
it's like if you believe in it and work
on it enough
then eventually you find the angle or
you find the pop that then opens it up
so it could go either way it just
depends on how your delusions of
grandeur i guess
yeah definitely so the the joke starts
with you being like oh it'd be funny to
have a basketball announcer that's
sexual innuendos but then
you go into the players names but the
joke grows from
that to the passing and then like
swirling around the rim so like you add
new dimensions to it
um first off how long did you work on
that joke would you say before you
performed it on
conan um
that was um
one of my early jokes and then it like
yeah developed
over a year so probably like three three
years
three or four years so it starts with
that initial idea of a announcer that
does
like sexual innuendos so then how did
you start to
piece it together to all those different
layers of the passing and then the back
and forth you know and then
the swirling around the rim and the shot
clock tag and like how
and where did those start to fall into
place
yeah i mean if you don't know the joke
if someone's listening to this
it's about kind of lingus um
i guess i should have prefaced the whole
thing with that i'll uh i'll play it in
the audio version of this for people
okay cool um yeah so just trying to
pretty much like just combine those two
things like where
do these like overlap what's the venn
diagram for these two things
and like um i think like
it's funny like trying to communicate
with your partner about sex
too and it's like um
just like what are like some simple
moves
like just to like get them to understand
like what you want them to do and so
uh yeah i think like passing and
swirling like
i was just like come on it's too easy
the fundamentals yeah fundamentals
that's good
yeah there's a tag there's a tag yeah
obviously yeah
kidding it was on tv i'm not doing
anything
right yeah yeah yeah
but that's just like a fun one to do you
can always like throw stuff
in a lot like when you're doing it live
and like people
just like even if they have never
watched basketball it's like
just like a fun joke everybody loves it
yeah and that's that's why i picked that
one because it has a
very clear defined
premise and it's executed very well
because like
we had mark normand on here one of his
big things was like
the joke has to be clear a lot of times
the audience isn't laughing because they
don't
understand what you're trying to say so
i picked that joke of yours because it's
very clear what the idea what the
premise is
and then you're just able to build on it
and add those different layers and take
us on a journey with it so that's
that's really why i picked that one
because like it's it was a very
it was just very well executed from an
organizational standpoint
yeah and if you listen to it again like
i do spend a lot of time setting it up
because there's like um a good chunk in
there where there's like
i'm not telling a joke i'm just like
saying like
you have to communicate with your
partner and like
people are like waiting for the joke but
it's not really there until
like i'm actually like passing the
basketball you know
so um it's kind of scary
in a way because but i like i know that
the joke is there so i'm not scared but
i think people are like
uh what's happening right now i haven't
laughed in a minute
um but i think it's just like then the
tension is like released
so it helps but especially with your
pacing i'm sure at some point they're
like uh oh where is she gonna take us
here
but yeah you don't lead us astray
i love it yeah you're good at it i think
it's analogies like you do with marriage
and costco like you're good at finding
connections between seemingly
unconnected
like ideas
with uh with the costco joke was that
like one of the jokes with the honey
bunches of oats was honey bunches of
oats like the first cereal you picked or
did you go through
um a few iterations of like cereals or
maybe it's a big jar of pickles like did
you go through different iterations that
way as well
yeah i thought about like different
things that i would get at costco like
trail mix or something but like i think
tiny bunches of votes
it's just like more personal for me
because like i grew
up grew up like my mom would always get
those like two packs
and then we'd like always have to eat
honey bunches of oats
and it's like a good cereal but it's
like oh man you can get sick of it so
fast
um so just like the visual for me of
like the
two bags of uh honey bunch of votes was
the one that stuck out awesome
yeah let me um well i've asked my
questions i've nerded out on your comedy
and we have some people
um posting here some questions so
i think we're ready to get to some fan
questions if you are
yeah i don't think i have any fans but
what
i'm telling you like you we had shane
torres on here yesterday
and i feel like we had more people
responding
about you being on here than shane so
give yourself some credit here
oh nice yeah see more validating change
you got the you got the uh hot breath
bump it's not about the conan bump
anymore it's about the hot breath bump
yeah i got to work with shane um in
sunnyvale at rooster t feathers and this
was before
it was like just when i started talking
to jp about conan
and shane has done conan multiple times
so i got to talk to him about it and he
was like super helpful
with like um just like kind of
easing my stress about like not hearing
back from him he's like don't worry
about it it's gonna happen
like it just takes time so he was like
super helpful in that process
i love that and what i love about
catching you at this
moment in your career just five years in
is that you're only gonna keep
progressing and just keep getting better
and more established
uh because yeah you're i mean you're
definitely yeah i mean you're in it it's
just time and consistency at this point
yeah the talent's there so it's exciting
to like i love been doing hot breath
like five years and there's several
comics to where it's like
interview them before they maybe even
have a tv appearance and now they're
like the star of a show or something
like that it's
it's the hot breath bump we call it here
so actually what we're gonna do is bring
in
we're doing this for the first time for
you emily we're bringing in the
the comic that actually requested i
posted a poll on the hot breath
instagram
requesting who people wanted to hear on
the show and this entire week has been
devoted to those requests
so we're actually going to invite the
comedian
that requested you his name's aaron
patrick
and he has a question he wants to
ask you about comedy
in hopes that um
this works because we've never tried
this before so we're gonna see what
happens here
so aaron are you there
that's how this happens oh oh let me see
if we can
add him i'm calling him
paging aaron
[Music]
this works aaron because we've never
tried this before
let's see are you there can you see can
you all see each other
uh aaron are you there hello
oh there's like um an echo oh yeah can
you uh
sorry aaron
let me see if there's um
a way for all three of us to be in here
or how i can uh
never done this before so this is
exciting
and then he just left yeah
he's like oh never mind he got nervous
um this may be a way to do it for now
um until i figure it out i could just
share the screen
uh where'd he go
[Laughter]
do we really just lose him i think he's
a
i think he's getting headphones or
something oh okay
this is his big debut you know we don't
want him to
oh and i see there's a picture and
picture on um
let me hide this real quick how do i
hide a picture in picture
i don't know i don't use skype oh yeah
it's like my first time i've used skype
in years you guys got me yeah hey
yeah let me um i'm gonna try something
real quick
so i don't um
because right now it's yup picture and
picture oh let me close it
oh there we go all right
all right so let me oh let me zoom out
now we're all in there okay
see i'm glad i'm glad we're doing this
thank you for your patience with this um
uh emily um
we're all learning this is now this just
became a terrible zoom
open mic this just
there we go okay very cool it worked
that's so exciting all right good stuff
yeah so um aaron you can all see each
other
yep yeah so cool oh my gosh this is
exciting
so um aaron's the comedian that actually
requested
you to be on the show emily so aaron uh
maybe just like a little about your
comedy experience and then what's your
question buddy
yeah well um nobody wants to hear about
me so
um but i will say so emily the first
time i saw you
i was out in la last summer for a work
conference
and uh one of my all-time favorite
comedians is pete holmes
and i saw he was opening for kyle
dunnigan
and sarah silverman was on the show and
i was like i'm gonna go
i was by myself i showed up and i got to
sit front row
dead center and then they came out and
announced you and i was like oh i have
no idea who this is
and like killed it like destroyed the
room
everybody was like cracking up laughing
the like you did the basketball bit
and i can't remember if you did it there
or if i sell it online but the
the hiccup bit about like whenever you
get the hiccups everybody becomes an
expert about how to get rid of them
and i'm like dying laughing and
like it was a really cool show for me
because
i was literally like month one of my
stand-up career and to see you like
to go through do a full set as like the
opener and then to see
pete holmes and sarah silverman and uh
just like
running new material and i've never
experienced that like
now going out to open mics everybody's
doing new material what that's like but
to see somebody like that and then
uh to see you on the show was really
cool and just been kind of following
since then
and um i know uh the one question i
wanted to ask is i'm coming up on my
one year anniversary for doing stand up
which still seems
a weird thing to say anniversary doing
stand-up but
uh i was wondering if someone like
yourself you're five years in
you sort of climb that comedic mountain
of
conan which i'm sure you're i don't
wanna like say you're tired of talking
about
but uh um i don't know if you're enough
but um
but um it's like is that the only
question
so um but i'm working on slowing down my
breath
you're doing great you're doing great
aaron this is this is big hop right
debut here
yeah uh so the big question i wanted to
ask was
um if you could go back to yourself at
the end of your first year
what advice would you give yourself
oh that's a good question thanks
um i would um
i think by the end of the first year i
was like still
not really convinced that like comedy
could be a thing for me
um it's like kind of you're in a weird
spot because you're not really doing
good shows yet i assume like i wasn't
i was just doing open mics and um
it like was fun and like i made friends
but it wasn't
like i couldn't picture it beyond that
and so i think what i would tell myself
is just like
uh work harder
like keep doing it stop like slacking
off like
you you love doing this so do it like
don't try to like have you know
different things going on just in case
like
this isn't gonna like keep going i would
just be like go for it you know
kind of like all in or nothing yeah or
just like
yeah stop slacking off like stop doing
the same jokes every night
and stop drinking so much like
just like take it like take it more
seriously just like try it
it's not it's not like bad to like try
for something you know
yeah um and i think i figured that out
eventually but
like after like two years maybe like in
the first year i'd be
i would tell myself to like uh
try harder yeah yeah because that's
that's one thing
mock like i come from a really blue
collar family and so my dad kind of
instilled with me like if you're gonna
do something like if it's cut in the
grass if it's doing a job
you like you go all in if you want to be
successful at it and
it's very interesting to me that i see
people uh
around where i do comedy that are so
funny
so hilarious and you're just like what
are they still doing here like why are
they at the open mic
at 1am going up two spots before me
when i've been doing this for six months
and i've slowly started to realize if
you
do the little things like you said just
work a little bit harder and take it a
little bit more seriously
you get opportunities that other people
you're like
because i'm sure this has probably
happened to you or you get on like you
get offered a show and you're like how
did i
i shouldn't be here like what like what
what am i
doing here like so yeah yeah so that's
awesome awesome so it helps validate me
what i'm trying to do now so awesome
yeah and like you're saying like the
largo it's like a
special place because you see these like
big time comedians just like trying
stuff
out you know for the first time and like
i can't do that when i'm at largo i like
bring my a
plus material because it's like you know
i come out and people are like
who is this i'm here to see sarah
silverman who is this
chick um so but i kind of like that too
because i'm like all right i have to
like
prove myself um in this venue
like i don't belong here you're right
but i'm gonna
try to prove you wrong
but you also took the leap you went from
santa cruz to san francisco to l.a
so i mean you honestly believed in
yourself and i think taking the leap is
something a lot of young comics struggle
with so like
what went to your decision of saying
okay i'm gonna take it from san
francisco to la i'm just gonna go for it
yeah that was a little bit of an easier
leap
just because um i felt like i'd been
there for so long that i was
i didn't really have anywhere else to
grow
um or like be
challenged um so i was like i gotta
i gotta challenge myself a little bit
more so then i
moved to la um but like
i think like the santa cruz to san
francisco was hard because i was like oh
i'm actually am i doing this like i'm
moving
to a different town for comedy
but then like the san francisco to la i
was like already doing comedy at that
point
so i was like yeah this is what i have
to do
like there's no other choice um
[Music]
so yeah just diving in and it's like
it's hard change is hard
um being challenged is hard it's like
starting over in a way
and that sucks um what's that early
grind
like the day job and what is that early
grind of i'm doing this but then reality
sets in of like oh i
still have like to stay alive and eat
yeah it sucks
[Laughter]
uh i mean i still uh
i still do like work
like because i gotta eat yeah it's uh i
wish
that i didn't have to working sucks
what is what is the work like what is
what is your date cause i mean that's
some
yeah i mean every comedian has to go
through so like what is what is the
balance you're having to do right now
um i try to work as little as possible
that's my whole goal sorry she's taking
her own advice aaron
[Laughter]
no i mean like on other stuff but like
as much as i can i'll
like write um but that doesn't seem like
work to me that's just like
i i have to do this this is
why i'm alive um which is i don't know
crazy because it is a lot of work if you
think about it like you spend so many
hours
trying to do comedy um
it's your whole life but it just feels
good feels better
what about you
yeah i do like freelance um stuff
like remotely for like this uh law firm
but it's like just tedious like data
entry type stuff
very nice yeah part a that's part of i
mean that's
that's what comedians need to hear
though is that oh man she's doing it she
moved to l.a
and she was on conan and she gets to
perform with like sarah silverman this
is crazy but it's like hey
i mean this is still comedy and it
doesn't pay
until way after you've paid your dues
like
most most of the time that's the case so
it's important for communities to hear
that as well that like
they're you're making sacrifices for
these opportunities you're getting it's
not just like
they magically happen because you were
tapped by the comedy gods
it's this is part of the comedian
lifestyle that people need to know
yeah no money you gotta know that
hey joel is it cool if i ask one more
question go ahead aaron you have the
floor
so i know you said you like talking and
hanging out with other comedians just
kind of
talking to shows and stuff and one of my
favorite things as a newer comedian
is just to find out and discover
different comedians i might not have
known about so i like to always ask
people
um what would be your mount rushmore of
comedy so like if you could choose just
four comedians and they don't have to be
stand up they could be
tv comedians like uh writers whatever it
is i'm always interested to see what
other comedians have to say
to that dude that's such a hard question
that's what literally everybody always
says
the oh man i don't know
for me it's probably like i'm not like a
big um
comedy like fan
i guess like i didn't really grow up
watching comedy i kind of just started
getting into it after i started
like so um
like the like the people that i started
watching were like
uh sarah silverman uh louis ck
um nina take notaro
um so i was like then i had to like go
back and like do some like
you know watch like older comedy like
mitch
hedberg and stuff like that um so like
i don't really know anything about like
the
great comedians no it's okay i know
it's not it's not a trap question to
make you say oh she didn't say richard
pryor she didn't say
you know this person it's just always
interesting to me to hear
who are some of the people's like
influences and people that they grew up
because i grew up when
the comedy central 30-minute specials
we're on like every
friday night um and that's kind of what
my like love of comedy and and
everything like that and then saturday
night live with guys like sandler and
farley and spade and everybody and
um so like i said it's just always
interesting yeah
i think like a big influence that like
would probably be
um one of my top four would be tina fey
just like i grew up watching her um like
snl
30 rock like i was just like obsessed
um and she was like
she's not a comedian i guess but like
her writing was so
like personal it was like oh i relate to
this and everybody else
can relate to this and nobody else is
like talking about this
for some reason which is comedy i think
um
so she she would be up there for sure
and yeah um
well that was four you didn't know i'm
gonna yeah that's all i'm gonna say
because
there's so many and i i hate like
choosing
yes everybody's so different but gotcha
you just get hit with all the people you
didn't mention after this and say why
didn't you mention me
you were going to be on the show now
you're not anymore yeah exactly
yeah how did you not say conan how did
you not say it
it's all political can't talk about it
awesome but yeah aaron where are you
based again uh baltimore maryland oh
cool
nice how's the scene out there
it's good it's good they're
before all this started literally the
week before everything shut down
uh there was a it was almost like a
stand-up game going on
uh there was a tuesday night where there
was literally i think it was six
open mics and uh one of the comedians
put a challenge
of like how many people can hit all six
so like people are like running in and
out of doors and everything
and i didn't find out about all the mics
until like that night
because i was on one of the shows and
uh so i was kind of like i felt kind of
left out but it's definitely
growing here like pretty much every
night of the week there's somewhere
some you know either a dive bar or a
venue that's doing a show
uh fridays and saturdays are always
pretty busy with you know
opportunities to get stage time and
everything so it's definitely growing in
this area that's for sure
that's great yeah
oh that was so cool yeah
and i just figured out how to get us all
three um
anyway it doesn't matter we're we're all
three in it the whole time but i was
trying to figure out the layout
and um as you two are con look we're
connecting comedians across the coast
this is so cool
that's great awesome i i feel like a
a star maker what if you two like grow
up to be like the next great comedians
and i'm like it was here
and i'm still just in my home office
just like remember guys it's all good i
hope so
well we won't forget about you
what was your name again it'll pop up in
our yearly feed on facebook
yeah well aaron patrick man this was
great thanks for
requesting emily and asking such great
questions
yeah thank you no problem all right have
a good day erin
thanks wow
that was cool that was our first time
doing that
so yeah good job figuring it out
we might be on to something here um
so let's um we have we could just get
maybe like two questions
um from fans because this
one was from imre who asked this might
be a stupid question
about conan but is there a warm-up comic
that gets the crowd ready
um yeah i'm blanking on his name right
now
um but i believe he started in san
francisco
man i i'm so bad with names um but
really funny guy he um
yeah he warms up the crowd before every
show
and then conan comes out and does his
thing and then there's a guest and then
the comic so i was able to go out into
the
studio and watch the warm-up comic
um and conan's like um
little like he did like a little skit
and then um then had the guest
it like goes by so fast it's crazy but
yeah the warm-up comic
he he wasn't he doesn't really do jokes
or when i was there he wasn't really
doing jokes but he like
he would like bring people from the
crowd onto the stage
and then like make them dance and like
the
and then like there was like a winner or
something so it was like very like crowd
heavy like uh just like making fun of
people pretty much like roasting their
outfits and stuff
yeah and that's uh if i'm re like like
every comedy show
has a warm up comic if tv shows have
warm-up comics and it is
it's a skill set within itself uh brody
stevens was known to be a really good
warm-up comic because it requires a lot
of
energy and interaction and they play
games and they'll throw candy into the
audience and things like that like
it's to really just gas up to quote um
pete holmes and gossetop
it really um you really just got to gas
it up
so yeah did you did you uh get to have
an interaction with conan
by the way did you get to yeah
so that was like probably um
the coolest part of it like i didn't
meet him before my set
so like walking out like him introducing
me
and me walking out that was the first
time like seeing him
um so
and then after my set um he came over
and was like emily catalano and then we
cut to commercial and then he just
stayed there with me
uh for like five minutes just like the
crowd was still there
and we were just talking like not miked
up or anything but just like he was
we were just talking about the set and
he was like so nice
and i did that um i did that joke
about um like don't marry
nathan brown yeah and
yeah so
like the first thing that
conan said to me when he walked over
after he was like upset he was like
please tell me that you used his real
name
and i was like yeah that's his real name
and he was like all right i'll pay for
your legal fees
um and
but luckily like nobody sued me or
anything but um
that was it was just really cool of him
he's just like a nice he's so
funny in person like way funnier in
person than
like on tv i think but like how so just
so
like every other work like line that he
says
is a joke he's just like always joking
um and then like he like
we went up back to the stage like with
my friends later
just like take pictures and stuff and
nobody else was there but then
uh conan walked out from like backstage
and like took pictures with everybody
and stuff so he's just like
super cool this uh nathan brown
joke did was there any was there any
blowback or
did nathan know this was going on tv and
uh no nobody knew uh
yeah i didn't even tell my mom like she
was watching and i guess she like
freaked out when she was watching and
she like started screaming
because she had no idea um
but i i haven't heard from nathan i've
heard from like some of his
um family
um members that i still like and in
contact with
and they were like um yeah i saw you on
conan great set
like waited way to kill it like oh
so i'm sure not everybody appreciated it
but like a
few people like you know can take a joke
so wait did you actually marry this guy
and now you're not
type deal yeah we were married
uh before i did comedy
how old were you i was 27
okay okay yeah so
then i started comedy it's easy to
remember because i
started comedy like a few weeks after i
turned 30 i think it was like a midlife
crisis or something but
yeah good that's that's great though
yeah it's never too late to start
yeah congratulations
that's hilarious that you said his name
and location
and there's been no blowback so that's
cool
no i mean it's a pretty like common name
so
i think people probably just assume i
made it up
very nice well kudos to nathan for being
a good sport
or actually or like you said that guy
sucks so maybe he just
sucks so much he's like yeah i suck too
much
yeah it's fine we don't talk so it's not
like
it's time why the life you've lived i
look forward to hearing more about this
as your comedy progresses you getting
into that
that uh type of stuff yeah
all right let's get to the final one
here and um can you
can you move your camera trying to think
maybe to your right a little bit there
we go
yeah there we go yeah oh i was just like
leaning yeah it's uh because on the
screen it um
on the we're on a split screen in the
stream so
it kind of makes the windows smaller so
okay
oh gary cannon is the warm-up comic's
name
gary cannon yeah very cool
shout out to gary that's a hard job
that's
that's requires physical effort to be a
warm-up comic so yeah
i couldn't do it i don't have that much
oh that would be hilarious if you go out
there and it's like hey
yeah i'm here to get you all turnt up
for family feud
are y'all ready for this
but it is cool you got to work with like
um like
tig and sarah and you see
that that skill set like
at at the highest form like you're
seeing masters of
that sort of performance so i bet you've
learned
you got to learn so much just from
seeing them executed
live that had to have been just like a
boost of like oh that's what's possible
you know
oh yeah for sure like tig is like
um just on another level of that you
know
so confident like in the silence
but it's like it's the best when
you can pull it off like that you know
and just like watching it live
is amazing yeah so let's get into um
let's get into this final question here
this is from chase
bonnin he asks oh wait never mind that's
a comment
and he has a question up higher his his
comment was not drinking or slowing down
drinking seems to be a theme for most
pro-working comics
not drinking or drinking slowing down
yeah likes or drinking less seems to be
a big piece of advice a lot of
professional comics
and then the person right after them
says ron white drinks on stage
so there's always there's always
exceptions
but yeah i mean
i didn't stop drinking i think it was
more like
i'm not going out just to drink
like um i'm going out
for the comedy yes i don't know
if that makes sense it makes perfect
sense because a lot of comics especially
early on
treat it more like a social club or like
a meet-up
but it's like i mean you're not here to
get drunk you're here to work on the
craft of comedy yes you could talk to
other comedians and
make friends and things like that but
the number one
goal of every single show should be
you're getting on stage and getting
better
it's not how many shots can i get for
free from the audience or something like
that
like it's a job and that was a big thing
shane
torres said yesterday was like you know
comedy if you want to be a job you have
to treat it like a job that's huge
i agree here we go all right so chase's
question this will be the final one
chase says being newish are you still
finding new writing techniques and do
you have a ritual
that helps you write
yeah um
i yeah i'm always looking up like
or i'm always like trying to find like
the best way to write which i haven't
found yet
but it's just like really hard so for me
like the more time
i can spend writing the better so
just for me is like a lot of time
writing i use like google docs and i
just
will write every anything like i'm
thinking about
and it's like a lot of very not funny
stuff but it's just like maybe this
topic will
turn into a joke later or i'll find i'll
find the punchline later
um so it's just a lot of time
not being funny just kind of
more like journal entry type stuff um
and that's been my process so far
um but now i i don't have
the secret to writing yet but maybe
someday
i'll let you know you did mention
earlier
when you're doing the basketball joke a
venn diagram are there other techniques
you'll plug into jokes to test them out
yeah i think when i'm like doing like
comparison
looks like that or like analogy that's
like a good way
like just like make two lists of things
um
i think it's like good for like topical
jokes too
if you're like oh trump everything you
can think about trump and then
everything
you can think about coronavirus or
something and see like
what can like match up and what will
you know what you can compare but
otherwise it's you basically just like
free writing
just journaling and
yeah basically yeah because i think like
the comedy that i like is um
like personal um and i think
i like to spend time writing jokes that
like only i can say
boom yes um
so like the more personal i can get
um i think the better because then you
don't have to worry about like oh did
somebody else already
do this it just saves a lot of time
so that's what i try to do but sometimes
you know your personal stuff isn't
funny yet and what what about when
you're saying a lot of it's not
it's just not funny which i think is
important for comics to hear
that it's okay that 80 of what you write
isn't like worth keeping i just heard uh
seinfeld saying interview like nine out
of ten of his jokes
he ends up not keeping so it's normal
and that is
part of the work of comedy which is why
most people
don't figure out like how to write jokes
because it is like a law of numbers and
the more you write the more chances
you're giving yourself
to find a joke but it really is just a
lot of
writing about not funny things until
something like sparks
yeah and i think like maybe the first
step before writing
like the punchline is finding something
interesting
or a topic that's interesting to you or
like something that you
haven't heard anybody else talk about
before
um because if you can like
capture like interest in the setup
then the punchline whatever it is
is gonna hit that much harder because
people are already invested in what
you're saying
um i think that's like
one of my theories
that's gold right there if you can
capture interest in the setup
the punchline will hit that much harder
that's
that's gold right there
we found it we found it hot breath of us
we have excavated the gold mine let's
get her out of here before she regrets
it
no oh that's so cool this is awesome
thank you for doing this this was this
was our first time like taking requests
and then like seeing him
come live on the air and then get to
connect with the guests that request
it's just it's very cool very cool of
you to do this so
how can us as the hot breath the verse
uh how can we like support you follow
you like tell us what you have going on
um yeah you can follow me on instagram i
post
like a bunch of clips so that's like a
cool way to like
um see more of my comedy and you can
like
share them with your friends and stuff
that would help and um
yeah i started doing a live zoom show
with my roommates
i live with some other comedians so we
do a live
show every thursday so we have one
tomorrow it's at seven o'clock
um our time california time
um and yeah you can dm me if you want
like the link
um and that we like just try
it's kind of like it's not an open mic
but we like try to have like new
material
every week just like and it's probably
all going to be about
uh the quarantine but it's like
it's fun and we we drink a lot
so your advice
your advice is that you would work
harder and drink less and then the
thing you're going to close the
interview on is it's a zoom
excuse to get drunk on the internet
yeah well now i can drink i'm you know
i'm a famous comedian now so now i can
drink
that's true you got the hot breath bump
so you are there
now yeah you gotta put the work in i
deserve it
well hot breath the verse go support
emily
and all of her projects if you found
this helpful
reach out to her on social media let her
know how great this interview was and
show your support for her and the show
if you want to get involved in more of
these q and a's in the future
go into the description of this episode
click the link to join the facebook
group and you can start interacting with
listeners from around the world
but for this episode we out here
so let's give a round of applause to
emily catalano one more time
thank you for your time emily and uh
thanks for having me
have a good day hot breath verse